[Musique]
la coutume veut que le prétendant donne
des cadeaux à sa Valentine
14 février fête des amoureux et depuis
longtemps mais de nos jours comme les
Valentins frappés par le coup de foudre
le sont aussi pour le coup de la vie il
se contente d'adresser des cartes à
cette époque les enfants aussi écrivent
des cartes et on leur propre conception
de la Saint-Valentin et de l'amour c'est
la fête des amoureux et ça c'est pour
les plus vieux
l'amour ne m'intéresse guère moi je
pense plutôt à mes études
et les adultes vous connaissaient
Cupidon
des amoureux
Cupidon c'est le dieu de l'amour c'est
un petit ange qui est représenté dans la
mythologie grecque en Grèce c'était
amour
la Saint-Valentin est à l'origine une
fête païenne de l'antiquité que l'Église
a converti en fait religieuse oh c'est
sûrement un des grands amoureux de
l'histoire chacun à Saint-Valentin
formation de boîte de chocolat ça
m'énerve facile à Saint-Valentin j'ai
tellement peur de pas être vendu
[Musique]
pourvu que ce soit un beau gars qui me
croque les vendeurs d'huile de lingerie
érotique font également recettes à la
Saint-Valentin
[Musique]
discrètement puis passer vite à la
caisse
de la sensualité au grand classique les
fleurs on va aussi des sacs de pétales
de roses c'est pour faire un chemin
jusque jusqu'au lit jusqu'au salon
jusqu'à la table je me souviens d'une
cliente qui avait appelé à moi
beaucoup d'anecdotes chez les fleuristes
mais surtout beaucoup de travail
on va dans les restaurants on va dans
les épiceries on va partout on nous
parle d'amour que si on vit pas d'amour
dans la vie c'est plus difficile alors
des câlins gratuits pourquoi pas pour
ajouter du bonheur et de la joie dans la
vie des gens juste pour comme amener un
petit côté qui est tout sauf matériel
surtout de l'amour
Canada Montréal
[Musique]